well the pentagon is set to make an
announcement aimed at easing concerns
members of the military have
about getting the coronavirus vaccine
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin joins us from the pentagon with
the details on the forthcoming
announcement hi jennifer
hi jillian well we expect that press
conference at 3
15 today fox has exclusively obtained
new data from an online survey of
military families
showing there has been some improvement
since december
among those concerned with getting the
vaccine now 70 percent of troops
surveyed say they have gotten the
vaccine or plan to do so
only 39 percent of active duty spouses
say
they plan to get vaccinated which could
be a problem as hundreds of thousands of
troops and their families
plan to move to new bases this summer
blue star families and covid
collaborative which conducted the survey
have made the following recommendations
to the pentagon
offering a choice 66 percent of active
duty service members say a choice in
type of vaccine
pfizer versus moderna versus johnson and
johnson
increases their likelihood of receiving
one guaranteeing time
off 22 percent of active duty service
members reported difficulty in obtaining
an appointment
that fits with their schedule increasing
information to military connected
spouses 30 percent of active duty
spouses
remain unsure if the vaccine is
available to them
these posters throughout the pentagon
show new incentives for those who have
been vaccinated nick palmisiano a former
army infantry officer who started the
clothing company
ranger up explained troops concerns
there's a general lack of trust anytime
the government's involved
you know whether you're talking about
the anthrax vaccine back in the day that
cause
problems or burn pits or all these
things that it kind of
the military is used as a guinea pig
this former combat veteran just got his
second covet vaccine
and is working hard to convince other
troops and veterans
about why they should do the same for
god and country
jillian right thanks for breaking it
down for us as always jennifer griffin
we appreciate it